if you're a Nintendo fan you don't want
a Super NES classic edition console you
need a Super NES classic edition console
from bonafide classics like Super Mario
well - the never before released starfox
- the Super NES classic is going to be
the must-have product of 2017 when it
officially launches in September
well most stores sold out of Super NES
classic pre-orders pretty much
immediately it's not quite time to panic
yet you can still get a Super NES
classic it's just going to take a lot of
time attention and patience or a lot of
money your choice
heading to ebay the most reliable way to
get a Super NES classic is to buy one
from scalpers on eBay
just be warned it's going to cost you
consider how 2016 s limited edition NES
classic which was manufactured in even
smaller quantities that than the Super
NES classic retailed at $60 officially
it's sold out everywhere but savvy
buyers turned to eBay to sell off their
extra consoles and ticked up the price
tag - three or four times here which a
no asking price judging by the few Super
NES classics already listed on eBay it
looks like that trend is going to
continue as of the making of this video
a prices fall between $200 and 4 350
dollars which is a mint higher than the
MSRP of 80 bucks
a price hike like that almost feels like
an assault yeah but since everyone wants
this console a sellers are going to milk
you for every buck they can if you do
decide to go the eBay routes here's some
advice look closely at the photos and
make sure that you're getting an actual
Super NES classic between customized
consoles meant to imitate the original
Nintendo product and straight-up
fraudulent listings with a little close
inspection you'll be able to tell the
difference between the new mini console
with pre-loaded games and some imposter
version Amazon third-party sellers you
can also try to buy a Super NES classic
from one of Amazon's third-party
merchants as with eBay these are
individuals or small companies who got
their hands on a Super NES classic and
decided to resell it usually at a marked
up price the Super NES classic isn't
listed yet on Amazon's partner stores
but it should be one
the console comes out on September 29th
2017 as with eBay make sure that you're
getting the right product if it somehow
stays games not included it's a no-go
because this thing should include over
20 awesome games also try to stick with
merchants with high ratings and lots of
reviews hey you might even get free
shipping thrown in on the deal Bernardo
walk to game stop if you live in a
relatively remote area check out your
local gamestop more the companies sold
out of Super NES classics online almost
immediately the brick-and-mortar stores
accepted pre-orders to that catch was
that you had to go to the store in
person by now what most of game stops in
major urban areas have probably burned
through their pre-order allotments but
areas are less densely populated might
still have a few pre-order slots open
once again however be prepared to pay a
little more than Super NES classics $80
asking price Game Stop knows that the
mini console is a hot item and to some
customers say that they had to bite
pricier bundles with other merchandise
to get their pre-orders in monitor the
web if you want to know when more Super
NES classic units become available
keep your Twitter feed open at all times
when the first round of pre-orders went
live journalists publications and the
gaming personalities quickly let their
followers know right away if someone
beat you to the punch
that's probably why Twitter feeds
devoted exclusively to video game deals
also helped spread the news if more
pre-orders become available or if extra
copies arrive on release day those same
accounts will probably let you know ASAP
of course if you look away from Twitter
for a mere second you risk of missing
the opportunity to score a pre-order so
you should probably only rely on this
technique if you're already a social
media addict did you see the memo
Roberta's same goes for those stuck
tracking websites sites like now in
stock that's routinely update to let
readers know if and when more pre-orders
become available so refresh refresh and
refresh again don't give up even if you
didn't score a pre-order you might be
able to get a Super NES classic and
sauce when it officially releases on
September 29th
[Music]
Toys R Us for example say that it won't
have any online pre-orders for the
machine while GameStop promises that it
will have a few units available for
walkins on launch day so if you do
decide that an in-person purchase is
your strategy of choice just make sure
to get to the store early very very
early especially if you live in a big
city you won't be the only person there
and most stores tend to handle big
releases like this on a first-come
first-served basis import a copy this
won't work if you want to be one of the
very first people to own a Super NES
classic but if you're in a pinch you can
always try to import a console from
overseas while the NES classic is sold
out in the United States you can still
pick up a Nintendo Classic Mini Famicom
the Japanese edition of the device from
the popular international retailer play
Asia you will be making some sacrifices
of course if your desire for a Super NES
classic hinges on the Steaua keep in
mind that you'll be getting a version
modeled on the Japanese edition of the
Super NES which looks different from the
American version think outside the box
everyone is checking big outlets like
Game Stop Best Buy and Walmart for the
Super NES classic but that's not the
only place you'll be able to buy one
think a geek purveyor of nerd related
novelty items offered a handful of Super
NES classic bundles that lasted a little
bit longer than the other options
meanwhile B&H photo and video which
mainly focuses on camera equipment
offered a few consoles as well once the
Super NES classic comes out don't forget
to check off the wall brick-and-mortar
stores either last year the NES classic
appeared at Urban Outfitters which is
primarily a clothing store for hipsters
with money if there's any kind of shop
nearby that doubles in cool and trendy
tech or appeals to those on the cutting
edge of style it might be worth asking
the cashier or manager if they're going
to have the Super NES classic and stuck
what you never told me that before it's
a long shot but who knows he might
strike hitting gold thanks for watching
pick the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]